Caption: so shout out to the sponsors they make
Caption: this stuff happen it's been really
Caption: really cool to have all these guys come
Caption: on board and make this possible so that
Caption: we can have coffee carts we can have
Caption: drinks and nibbles after afterwards we
Caption: can have things like recordings
Caption: happening so we're sort of rolling the
Caption: dice with that one hopefully the
Caption: recordings come out okay so yeah if you
Caption: see these guys around say thanks also if
Caption: you see rob moore around give the guy a
Caption: hug right he's done such an immense job
Caption: to get what I kind of think is like an
Caption: international quality event happening
Caption: here in the lot of Perth which is really
Caption: cool if you're from cash converters
Caption: anyone from cashes here JD I'll do this
Caption: on Friday go see another talk like
Caption: seriously like oh we'll do this again
Caption: there's some other cool stuff happening
Caption: right um let's kick off so what my talk
Caption: is going to be about is low latency and
Caption: we'll find out why it's not actually
Caption: that low latency later this is sort of a
Caption: review of what I learnt when I moved to
Caption: London I worked here in Perth eight
Caption: years ago with some of the guys in the
Caption: room and then I did the jump to London
Caption: and this is sort of me finding out what
Caption: I didn't know that I didn't know if when
Caption: I went there so hopefully is a chance to
Caption: demystify some of the things that happen
Caption: outside of maybe if you're living in
Caption: your own ecosystem here in Perth what
Caption: we're doing somewhere else which is kind
Caption: of fun
Caption: Who am I I wrote a book once so some
Caption: people know me about that but we don't
Caption: have time to cover this on the debit
Caption: cash ease I speak at things and I run
Caption: training on rx if you've heard of that
Caption: if you haven't come talk to me
Caption: afterwards I'm a small town boy never
Caption: been to Detroit I did however graph an
Caption: Auckland New Zealand time another
Caption: international speaker and
Caption: I cut my teeth on ASP and access build a
Caption: little Club I was a bit of a sports jock
Caption: a long time ago and built the clubs
Caption: water polo website which was really cool
Caption: that lasted ten years I found out ten
Caption: years later they're still using that
Caption: thing that's cool I graduated after
Caption: doing Java COBOL CVB five and gladly
Caption: took a role doing friendly old ASP with
Caption: slightly scary sequel server I did that
Caption: for a while
Caption: asp.net or dotnet came out I picked up
Caption: asp.net vb.net yup what up sequel server
Caption: get that loving relationship with sequel
Caption: server going that was really cool moved
Caption: over to purse sometime around there as
Caption: well and picked up c-sharp continued
Caption: with sequel server felt like I've done
Caption: everything in the web space we were just
Caption: doing the same old thing over and again
Caption: and that's when I moved to Bank West in
Caption: fact inside doing WPF WCF and that is
Caption: where things got really interesting it
Caption: was hanging on ice and manage memory now
Caption: I never had to do that in the web you
Caption: just send a request and things happen in
Caption: something disposed something garbage
Caption: collector and life was good right and
Caption: then I moved to London where WPF was
Caption: actually useful skill for me and it was
Caption: a bit of a case of worse what this is
Caption: not we're not in Kansas anymore where's
Caption: the sequel server where's the web server
Caption: no one's talking about WCF and why is
Caption: everyone always asking me about garbage
Caption: collection right so I've moved from sort
Caption: of retail banking though it was really
Caption: just more crud application kind of stuff
Caption: to the world of high finance trading
Caption: foreign exchange stocks equities pricing
Caption: bonds and all this kind of stuff and was
Caption: interesting that it was just very odd
Caption: that some things have just changed so
Caption: these are my top ten things that I'd
Caption: learnt on the way so hopefully I can get
Caption: them out to you quickly because ten
Caption: things 45 minutes that doesn't give me
Caption: much time to do go through so the first
Caption: thing I found out was know your targets
Caption: and I thought we're not going to move to
Caption: London in their world there was this
Caption: feeling of everything being super fast
Caption: and it was going to be amazing that
Caption: hardware was going to be the secret
Caption: sauce
Caption: have some special routers or some Intel
Caption: chip I've never heard of before wasn't
Caption: the case it was all about knowing your
Caption: targets and it's a balance between
Caption: under-delivering so just missing these
Caption: targets that we haven't thought about or
Caption: being those engineers that trace
Caption: perfection and we just keep going and
Caption: spend all the money until we've got this
Caption: really fast thing that actually we've
Caption: done haven't done all the other features
Caption: yet we've just made one bit very fast
Caption: and then the 3 ends of performance
Caption: measure measure measure so hardware
Caption: without targets I thought this was kind
Caption: of funny and guy watches the Tour de
Caption: France he loves cycling and is on his
Caption: daughter's bike in the driveway sees
Caption: Chris Froome and goes you know what I
Caption: think I could do that the only
Caption: difference between me and him is the
Caption: bike we'll probably not right it's it's
Caption: more than the hardware you can't just
Caption: throw hardware at a problem to go faster
Caption: and that's the point of that little
Caption: slide and so if it's not about hardware
Caption: it's about targets and measurement the
Caption: next question is measure what and if you
Caption: move on to that line of thinking you're
Caption: asking the right questions you're in the
Caption: right space so let's just go through
Caption: some terminology first which I didn't
Caption: quite understand these either at the
Caption: time so service time the time to
Caption: actually process the requests like
Caption: dictionary done we know all the words
Caption: now that's all you need to know right
Caption: because if it's the time - is there
Caption: anything else to do well actually
Caption: there's latency and this is probably the
Caption: most misunderstood or misused word when
Caption: leaving the title at low latencies not
Caption: low latency latency is the time spent
Caption: waiting to be processed so if I'm on a
Caption: website and I click a button the buttons
Caption: there we some JavaScript or something
Caption: that happens and then that'll send a
Caption: request but that will get buffered on my
Caption: network card in this time across the
Caption: wire then gets onto another network card
Caption: then we'll land on the queue on a server
Caption: somewhere the queue might be explicit
Caption: like 0 mq in service bus something like
Caption: that or it might be an implicit cute
Caption: like a thread scheduler or something
Caption: like that but there are queues
Caption: everywhere and is latency everywhere all
Caption: of that time is not processing the
Caption: requests that's getting my request to
Caption: the bit of code
Caption: to process it it's also time that's
Caption: latent so response time is the person
Caption: clicking that button is what they see
Caption: the latency plus the service time is
Caption: your response time so that was
Caption: interesting I never really considered
Caption: those three as a car obviously you only
Caption: need to measure two to get the other one
Caption: and then throughput is sort of the other
Caption: side of the coin is the rate at which
Caption: our requests or operations can be
Caption: processed sometimes there's a false
Caption: dichotomy about that you can talk about
Caption: this is not a trade-off between those
Caption: throughput and response time but some
Caption: people mistake that there is and then
Caption: the next thing I thought okay so we need
Caption: to measure and myself and quite a few of
Caption: the other team made the common mistake
Caption: of going all right well let's get the
Caption: medium response time that that seems
Caption: good we should report the median
Caption: response and wealthy report it we should
Caption: target the median response time and
Caption: what's the median response time is first
Caption: percentiles is the 50th percentile and
Caption: as then engineers now that we have a
Caption: target so we know when to stop when we
Caption: get say one second response time is our
Caption: median we're going to stop right we've
Caption: hit our target we move on and do
Caption: something else
Caption: what would actually be doing there is
Caption: saying 50% of our users will get at less
Caption: than one second response time what we're
Caption: also saying is 50% of our users will get
Caption: worse than one second response time that
Caption: seems like an odd target to have doesn't
Caption: it so then maybe the mean is a better
Caption: average well the mean anyone that's done
Caption: statistics you know you can make that
Caption: whatever you want kind of as gods
Caption: quadrant four different sets of
Caption: behavioral data shapes these all have
Caption: the same mean but quite clearly if these
Caption: were measurements taken from your system
Caption: they've all got different behaviors and
Caption: that takes me on to the point that I
Caption: learnt fairly recently if you do not
Caption: model your targets based on numbers do
Caption: we call it we
Caption: we found this out about six weeks apart
Caption: from each other we model shapes
Caption: behaviors as shapes okay so here we have
Caption: a nonlinear percentile distribution so
Caption: here we've got the zero the next one
Caption: isn't ten percent it's ninety percent we
Caption: jump straight to ninety percent ninety
Caption: nine and these are measurements of
Caption: latency or response time or service time
Caption: in our system and I can see very quickly
Caption: because I'm not actually that interested
Caption: in the ten twenty thirty all the good
Caption: results I'm looking at the bad results
Caption: these are these are the problem areas
Caption: you can see here that this curve is not
Caption: great even if it's linear you know it's
Caption: not that great but because it's
Caption: nonlinear we can actually see right and
Caption: close where our trade-offs are maybe
Caption: this lines good but then resolutions are
Caption: great but actually bumps up over and
Caption: there's a high line here maybe they
Caption: actually want this line something we can
Caption: trade off with our clients input and how
Caption: do we collect this data it's actually
Caption: really interesting from a data
Caption: collection point of view when you click
Caption: values and histograms you measure the
Caption: response time using hopefully a high
Caption: resolutions timer and then you put that
Caption: value in a bucket so it was one thing to
Caption: put it in the one second bucket it's two
Caption: seconds to put the two seconds bucket
Caption: and by doing that all you're really
Caption: doing the bucket just increments by one
Caption: assigned it to that and then your
Caption: fidelity of your buckets becomes
Caption: interesting it's a fast and efficient
Caption: way to store and record data and these
Caption: implementations already existing HDL
Caption: histograms great tool for doing that and
Caption: produces charts like this incredibly
Caption: fast tiny footprint well we're only up
Caption: to number two number two know your costs
Caption: something I found really interesting
Caption: working with or being associated with
Caption: some guys that were doing some high
Caption: perform so they all knew the cost or had
Caption: at least a vague idea of the cost of an
Caption: operation in their system so write down
Caption: low-level basic operations and increment
Caption: taking these verses measurements in
Caption: nanoseconds this is one nanosecond here
Caption: an incremental and addition tiny very
Caption: quick obviously write multiplication
Caption: interestings an order of magnitude
Caption: slower okay that's interesting division
Caption: three orders of magnitude slower than an
Caption: addition okay that's just mildly
Caption: interesting but let us say we look at
Caption: three safe implementations of these well
Caption: divisions actually not that expensive
Caption: anymore anatomic increments expensive
Caption: these are just measurements taken from
Caption: my machine your your mileage may vary
Caption: but I found that performance engineers
Caption: knew these costs and they knew for their
Caption: platform and maybe not specifically for
Caption: adding numbers but maybe hitting a
Caption: network or writing to a disk but they
Caption: knew their numbers relevant to their
Caption: system they also understood that not
Caption: everything is free just because it's one
Caption: line of code doesn't mean it's as cheap
Caption: as another line of code branching
Caption: inlining lots and care statements down
Caption: just the difference in the cost
Caption: trade-offs between each of these I
Caption: thought was very interesting so just for
Caption: comparison we had a quick look at that
Caption: chart and then increment and then
Caption: multiply was lesson in nanosecond
Caption: compared to say serializing DC rising
Caption: Jason in.net for example we go only get
Caption: about eight eight seconds to a million
Caption: DC realizations on this computer for
Caption: example just an interesting number to be
Caption: aware of eight million by a million
Caption: eight seconds okay interesting other
Caption: things this laptop can do and I kind of
Caption: think this is good to go back for me to
Caption: think about context I can every two
Caption: seconds move a gigabyte of data off the
Caption: disk on that laptop it's a two-year old
Caption: laptop I think that's really impressive
Caption: today that we can move that with some
Caption: pretty sophisticated software that's
Caption: been written
Caption: I can push 41 million messages across
Caption: the queue
Caption: 41 million messages on a second that's
Caption: pretty awesome right I can set up a
Caption: three node cluster on a three virtual
Caption: boxes on this machine and push 660
Caption: durable messages to it a second be quite
Caption: interesting numbers and this isn't me
Caption: boasting about how good this is or how
Caption: clever I didn't write any of that just
Caption: give you information on context right
Caption: and so something else they do because
Caption: sometimes it's just too hard to think
Caption: about nanoseconds it's such a small
Caption: number it sounds like it's free you put
Caption: it into scale and when you think about
Caption: one CPU cycle and compare that to memory
Caption: access memory access is cheap well it's
Caption: six minutes compared to the one second
Caption: theoretical
Caption: CPU instruction and then we look at
Caption: hitting the disk or human response time
Caption: those
Caption: numbers become very interesting right
Caption: and given response time 200 milliseconds
Caption: that's actually pretty quick right so
Caption: obviously I'd rather my computer to be
Caption: doing my algorithmic trading than a
Caption: person clicking on a button now this is
Caption: my number number one I kind of think you
Caption: have to get to this one first but this
Caption: is the biggest takeaway I think
Caption: visualize your flows know your flows
Caption: know how your data and your instructions
Caption: move through your system so big
Caption: o-notation
Caption: people often refer to that only for like
Caption: complex algorithms low-level stuff like
Caption: red black trees or quicksort versus
Caption: bubble sort kind of stuff I think it's
Caption: really applicable to high-level designs
Caption: as well I think this is a bit of a lost
Caption: art something that I think most of us
Caption: would be guilty especially I am and I'm
Caption: going to play a game with you I'm going
Caption: to show you guys free flow so I just
Caption: want you to shout out faster or slower
Caption: based on your gut feel if you think the
Caption: next slide when I show you the new side
Caption: is it faster or slower than the previous
Caption: slide so just you can almost cross your
Caption: eyes and look at that is the next time
Caption: faster or slower bar cell why just got
Caption: less less good perfect codes the enemy
Caption: right next one faster over boo can I
Caption: think fairly damning quotes I can think
Caption: of no the field of human endeavor that
Caption: allows levels of inefficiency we find
Caption: acceptable and software and it's only
Caption: because I didn't say it someone else
Caption: Moore's Law I found really funny that
Caption: there's maze lore as well which is
Caption: somehow we write software so crappy that
Caption: we compensate Moore's law meaning that
Caption: when I first moved here to first ten
Caption: years ago everything still a slope even
Caption: though that's a beast of a laptop so I'm
Caption: going to quickly skip over own notation
Caption: because I think we get what it is I
Caption: think it is an exercise for the audience
Caption: and I really would love it if everyone
Caption: did this and if you did tweet me later
Caption: just I know that someone did this but on
Caption: Monday just grab a flow any flow in your
Caption: system and just map it out
Caption: it out and those flows I just showed you
Caption: web sequence diagrams calm it's like so
Caption: easy a BA could use it draw a flow from
Caption: your system and just get a feel for what
Caption: your system actually does and don't
Caption: cheat don't go on you then it just does
Caption: this in the big method named Vito what
Caption: the method does as well so which slow I
Caption: would say anything that takes more than
Caption: a second I'm going to be a bit mean here
Caption: if you've got to build it takes an hour
Caption: 660 messages a second okay an hour okay
Caption: that's taking too long
Caption: got some unit tests that take ten
Caption: minutes it's too long okay you need to
Caption: from chicken be able to commit and put
Caption: it in production and 15 minutes absolute
Caption: maximum 15 minutes right so take an hour
Caption: to build you've lost the game you're
Caption: four times out just a reminder a
Caption: gigabyte every two seconds and you move
Caption: the gigabyte of data right 441 million
Caption: messages a second what are doing for an
Caption: hour so on Monday
Caption: you've got something like that draw the
Caption: flow surprise yourself and what we're
Caption: going to do now is kind of scary and I'm
Caption: not definitely not picking on anyone can
Caption: we see this here we go my mouse back my
Caption: mouse is back right so I had a slider I
Caption: don't know what I mean when I talk about
Caption: a slider a UI slider and it was it was I
Caption: do drag it across and numbers added up
Caption: was the personal loan amount this is
Caption: cool but something had happened and it
Caption: was like really just rain as I moved it
Caption: it was hard and it actually hurt my hand
Caption: cause I just gripped my mouse harder
Caption: okay so a couple of us got together and
Caption: we we put a timer around the myth the
Caption: property we're setting and dotting it
Caption: and it's a 125 milliseconds to 250
Caption: milliseconds to do this 50 milliseconds
Caption: is the budget you get to updating UI
Caption: anything after that is a noticeable lag
Caption: we blew our budget by five times okay so
Caption: we look at this thing and went well okay
Caption: it's just a prop
Caption: - this is cool I like this early
Caption: termination that's easy
Caption: what's going on here that only that was
Caption: a collection of three things that did a
Caption: little loop that was actually very cheap
Caption: we just set another property that looks
Caption: cheap we refreshed something and then we
Caption: fit some events off there's no problem
Caption: here what's going on 250 milliseconds
Caption: and then I think well let's dog food I'm
Caption: faint visualize you flows so what I
Caption: actually did was write down what we did
Caption: and a couple of us sat down and looked
Caption: at it and this is what it actually did
Caption: every time I poked some things that
Caption: poked another thing and it poked another
Caption: thing and approved another thing had
Caption: thing at what the is going on here
Caption: so notice that there's some things out
Caption: here does eight of these as well we call
Caption: this expensive method eight times 17
Caption: milliseconds it was which takes me back
Caption: to my other point identify your critical
Caption: path so we saw this thing it was taking
Caption: too long
Caption: sat down with some of the other devs in
Caption: the office we figured out how to fix
Caption: this and we identified the critical path
Caption: you can't effectively optimize if you're
Caption: not optimizing the critical path great
Caption: book will take your weekend to read it
Caption: it's like a story so it's fun to read
Caption: it's not like heavyweight and mud and
Caption: Fowler stuff you identify them you focus
Caption: only on that path now remember back on
Caption: this thing I had a I've got that take 17
Caption: milliseconds we could have done some
Caption: things and shaved off 2 milliseconds
Caption: that we called it eight times so we've
Caption: got 16 milliseconds off 16 milliseconds
Caption: off 250 milliseconds oh cool we only
Caption: blown the budget by four and a half
Caption: times what we did was reduce it down so
Caption: the whole thing took just two calls of
Caption: that so okay it still took 35
Caption: milliseconds that were under budget now
Caption: right identify the critical path fix
Caption: that don't muck around with number one
Caption: and two we could always go back and make
Caption: that faster but to what end so you also
Caption: notice that when you optimize the
Caption: bottleneck often what was number two
Caption: number two anymore it's not even number
Caption: one it's just one because you just don't
Caption: call it next mechanical sympathy no the
Caption: layer below which you operate Jackie
Caption: Stewart Formula one champion was worried
Caption: in the 70s that designers and drivers
Caption: was so specialized that they didn't
Caption: really know much about what the other
Caption: one did so he coined the phrase
Caption: mechanical sympathy as a term for the
Caption: driver and the machine working together
Caption: drivers didn't have to be able to build
Caption: their race cars but they had to have a
Caption: general understanding how the
Caption: constituent parts sit together and this
Caption: is now becoming a feature in
Caption: high-performance computing or low
Caption: latency computing just understand I
Caption: think it's applicable to all of us if
Caption: I'm a web dev I should know at what HTTP
Caption: is in TLS and how the Dom works right
Caption: don't just throw HTML tags at the
Caption: browser and hope if your arrest is and I
Caption: mean the kind of integration guy you're
Caption: doing HTTP already well then you should
Caption: definitely know how to LS works and TCP
Caption: and things like that
Caption: your WPF dev dispatcher logical physical
Caption: tree and if you're working on any of the
Caption: managed frameworks so the big head is
Caption: dotnet Java JavaScript
Caption: please understand how your virtual
Caption: machine works so that's the CLA the JVM
Caption: or v8 generally it gives you a good
Caption: insight again you don't have to build v8
Caption: but it's good to know how the thing
Caption: works if you're more in data area know
Caption: your page sizes I found this really
Caption: interesting the people I was working
Caption: with they weren't talking about the
Caption: sequel servers I was talking about cache
Caption: lines which was amazing about who cares
Caption: what the cache line size is but these
Caption: guys did if you're a sequel bid you
Caption: should know your page size because that
Caption: impacts how you design your database if
Caption: you're a network guy knowing how big
Caption: your frame packets are that can impact
Caption: your design if you're a bit toward or as
Caption: I call them knowing that a cache line of
Caption: 64 bytes can impact the way you design
Caption: things that was really interesting
Caption: seeing a stack overflow on dotnet
Caption: recently about why does my 5-bike stroke
Caption: run slower than an 8 byte struct five
Caption: smaller should be faster why is that
Caption: maybe some of you can talk about
Caption: afterwards but it does require you to
Caption: know your target platform no point
Caption: knowing what 2016 sequel server doesn't
Caption: in developing on 2005 right maybe
Caption: different things know your target
Caption: platform and to rob mores talked earlier
Caption: we should know the platform because
Caption: we're always thinking about going to
Caption: production right hardware is cheap gives
Caption: on and most water you can't afford
Caption: three-tails you can't race we should be
Caption: doing the same thing don't play with one
Caption: thing and prod put all the money into
Caption: prod a foxy remember that but all your
Caption: money into product or we don't have any
Caption: money left to have the same thing and
Caption: set or pre prod or give so you guys deaf
Caption: on sequel server and we'll put an Oracle
Caption: over there and part madness right how do
Caption: is chief you devs aren't your expensive
Caption: question authority which I thought was
Caption: great because the overage games are seen
Caption: on bullying that you grew up in the 90s
Caption: yeah so challenge conventional wisdom
Caption: but don't ignore it and as a 90's rocker
Caption: I missed that part it was challenged not
Caption: go yourself Authority it was like
Caption: question it right so TCP is the default
Caption: rule to me when I landed in London of
Caption: course PC piece of default it's what
Caption: keeps the internet working why would
Caption: that be a bad thing
Caption: conditions like ordering of messages
Caption: reliable irritate these are great
Caption: features to have but there's a three-way
Caption: handshake in the header sizes 20 bytes
Caption: compared to a UDP which is 8 bytes so
Caption: you kind of end up with this cold sling
Caption: which is probably what I would want if I
Caption: was traveling across Turkmenistan you
Caption: know and I needed to survive but if I
Caption: building a low latency system maybe I
Caption: would want that with no features and not
Caption: take the cost of all of that so that was
Caption: interesting I found out that many if not
Caption: all messaging systems in the low latency
Caption: space we're using UDP mind-blown right
Caption: no WCS out of interest um so C C++ is
Caption: faster right challenge the conventions
Caption: allows you to get close to the metal
Caption: which is cool but it can dilute the
Caption: focus so there was an example we're on
Caption: silverlight team and c++ back-end team
Caption: that I worked in London and we did have
Caption: an exceptionally talented art map team
Caption: working on Silverlight and the next beer
Caption: so over there doing C++ and we're all
Caption: very impressed but from a distance
Caption: because over this manner then we found
Caption: out we had doctors and PhDs and C++ guys
Caption: on the dotnet team and that's 18 months
Caption: Oh like that doesn't seem that that's
Caption: what they're doing online just doing
Caption: basic math I'm pretty sure they're off
Caption: by an order of magnitude what they
Caption: should be hitting and so after a couple
Caption: of drunken moments we decided you know
Caption: what you give it we spiked that we
Caption: presented it to the business and in nine
Caption: weeks three Deb's and I say Deb's they
Caption: were outstanding devs MC shark produced
Caption: the streamer the low latency part of the
Caption: system there was three times faster than
Caption: the C++ one interesting challenge
Caption: conventional wisdom that wasn't
Caption: impressive what the guys are doing over
Caption: in Java is impressive right we were just
Caption: trying to copy what some Java guys are
Caption: doing if you get a chance and you don't
Caption: already know it look up dis ruptor iran
Caption: SBE which are brought to you by Martin
Caption: Thompson
Caption: interestingly his blog is mechanical
Caption: sympathy so obviously I've got a man
Caption: crush on him
Caption: Todd Montgomery is sort of a partner in
Caption: crime actual NASA rocket scientist
Caption: mental and then at the other end of
Caption: scale theater building libraries like
Caption: this which just destroyed proprietary
Caption: software and specialized hardware and it
Caption: runs on Java what was going on here
Caption: we've got guys like Gil who are
Caption: producing JVM so instead of using the
Caption: Oracle one use his one and your system
Caption: will just go faster mental right okay
Caption: does it pay its way justify the costs of
Caption: your features your abstractions and your
Caption: libraries so if you're looking for
Caption: performance remember this is a
Caption: performance book not a dogmatic you must
Caption: do this if you're looking for the full
Caption: performance maybe you don't want these
Caption: in your system Auto notifies auto
Caption: Reuters or to anything auto it's doing
Caption: the work for you maybe you want to code
Caption: a little bit closer to the metal hour
Caption: ends I kind of like beating up on poor
Caption: old ORM I kind of think of them as the
Caption: compensating behavior for you have to
Caption: use relational database and don't use
Caption: cos and I want it to look like a
Caption: document databases and how does that
Caption: marriage will happen sterilization
Caption: choice we all love or someone says
Caption: let's use XML but no one thinks the last
Caption: when you say Jason which is still just a
Caption: big fat text format and so protocol
Caption: buffer is the de-facto in most places
Caption: but is quickly getting eclipsed by these
Caption: outrageously fast and more encoding than
Caption: serialization formats they're a little
Caption: bit leaky so generally you only use them
Caption: in your land but outrageously fast
Caption: SVA for example I don't think you can
Caption: make it any faster there's no more clock
Caption: cycles you can drop off that's pretty
Caption: cool and code reuse I found this very
Caption: interesting does it pay its way often
Caption: code reuse gets mixed up as the goal
Caption: it's not a goal it's an outcome of
Caption: sometimes you design software and it
Caption: works out and there's some code reuse
Caption: super it is not the goal of what we're
Caption: doing fast code is clean code so what I
Caption: find interesting is that we've got a
Caption: group here are very interested and
Caption: motivated developers because we took a
Caption: Saturday off to do this and we're
Caption: probably all preaching low solid DBM DDD
Caption: CTRs what was interesting was the low
Caption: latency guys were actually practicing
Caption: that they weren't talking about it so
Caption: much as actually doing it and I thought
Caption: again that the secret sauce is going to
Caption: be something else I thought this was
Caption: just for us mortals
Caption: right but the guys that were writing
Caption: fast code would practising all of that
Caption: kind of stuff especially single
Caption: responsibility principle very
Caption: interesting and as an exercise I'm just
Caption: going to jump out and show single
Caption: responsibility principle in action has
Caption: anyone heard of our X I think is that
Caption: popular in person at the moment we don't
Caption: do a lot of streaming of stuff I'm a bit
Caption: of a fan and so is Brendan foster hit
Caption: we're both sort of contribute to the
Caption: library and I did a purse change on it
Caption: recently there's a thing called a replay
Caption: subject everyone know what a callback or
Caption: an event is then it's not a trick
Caption: question
Caption: a replay subject basically means I can
Caption: register for that callback or the event
Caption: late and get previous values that's kind
Caption: of a neat feature temperatures changing
Caption: it's 27 degrees 28 degrees 29 degrees if
Caption: then there's a big gap and then I
Caption: subscribe what I really want to know is
Caption: the current temperature which really is
Caption: just the last event so I'd like a replay
Caption: with a buffer of one thing sounds like a
Caption: good tool so we were looking at this
Caption: thing and there was a problem guys are
Caption: seeing performance that they didn't
Caption: think was very good 220 messages are
Caption: second but that's pretty good right yeah
Caption: but this linear degradation double the
Caption: subscribers have the throughput I'm
Caption: saying loss seems like a trade-off night
Caption: seems a pretty expensive trade-off so we
Caption: looked at the toad a couple of us got
Caption: together cuz can't help ourselves and
Caption: let's just run a little example here we
Caption: say the subject and if I put one thing
Caption: through it so a subject is basically in
Caption: a way to create a callback I subscribe
Caption: to it here and just give it a name and I
Caption: put some value through it and I'll see
Caption: subscriber 1 get them then I put your
Caption: value after I subscribe to number 5 it's
Caption: tiny then what people sing that at the
Caption: back cool
Caption: so subscriber 1/2 things that's why I've
Caption: only got one two three four five and
Caption: then subscriber too because he screwed
Caption: up with skill forgets fight but what I
Caption: want is subscriber for subscriber to to
Caption: also see the current value so what I'm
Caption: going to do so like a buffer of one
Caption: coding life is ridiculous and then I'm
Caption: going to say yeah cool so when I
Caption: subscribed I got that value of four
Caption: because it was the current value so
Caption: that's not very clever but it helps lead
Caption: into what the problems were so is what
Caption: the cost of subscribing was it did some
Caption: stuff not too interesting for this talk
Caption: on meat is the pushing of the value so
Caption: I'm putting it in tell all the
Caption: subscribers scheduled observer so one of
Caption: the other things you can do with replay
Caption: subject does not just tell me the last
Caption: thing in tell me the last two minutes of
Caption: things last 10 hours I think so there's
Caption: a time component I don't have a time
Caption: compare I just want the last one and
Caption: then I stop watch what's what's that
Caption: goes and then time until all the time
Caption: concerns in here what's I'm not using
Caption: the time
Caption: of this now look at how it trends values
Caption: before it pushes them it was a queue
Caption: that's kind of nice that hang on I only
Caption: want the last one value why would I have
Caption: a queue
Caption: god this seems like it's doing lots of
Caption: stuff that I don't care about and then
Caption: we had a plan for you know what we can
Caption: make this a single responsibility
Caption: principle what the hell does happen
Caption: there
Caption: so one notice the shapes different we
Caption: don't have that degradation
Caption: every time I double my subscribers very
Caption: small impact right - for again we're
Caption: still up here now take a look at the
Caption: numbers 220,000 messages a second 50,000
Caption: messages a second 10 million messages
Caption: our second jump all the way out here at
Caption: 16 things we're still up in the millions
Caption: what happens there so let's scroll down
Caption: that was the old implementation if I
Caption: remembered all of that or this is not
Caption: the new implementation is it is sub
Caption: class an abstract class and it sent a
Caption: head to the buffer term the buffer and
Caption: then publish the values in subscribers I
Caption: can read that it's easy to read it's
Caption: clean and then what do i do i've got a
Caption: replay one implementation of this what
Caption: are you doing add a value to the buffer
Caption: there's no queue there's no time there's
Caption: no locks yes they have a value and the
Caption: value is this what's the trim buffer no
Caption: op I don't know what the content of
Caption: trimming the buffer is because I don't
Caption: have a queue when someone subscribes if
Caption: I have a value you can have the value
Caption: because it's already here nice and
Caption: simple right so going from this kind of
Caption: messy concerned had all the features
Caption: cool the winter single responsibility
Caption: principle all this unnecessary code into
Caption: a lot of exchanges locks been weights
Caption: thread sleeps mayhem all went away
Caption: without three orders of magnitude speed
Caption: out of that so G sees killed GCS what's
Caption: that government's collection so
Caption: allocations don't kill garbage
Caption: collections kill okay why and how going
Caption: back to our previous example I pushed a
Caption: million messages through 216 subscribers
Caption: six and a half thousand garbage
Caption: collections new implementation one zero
Caption: everywhere else okay that's kind of
Caption: interesting
Caption: all these allocations go away
Caption: you expect the GC pauses something Joe
Caption: Duffy recently was talking about agender
Caption: Oh talking nanoseconds gen1 milliseconds
Caption: into 10 milliseconds but I've heard of
Caption: 17 minute pauses and when your garbage
Caption: collector runs on most systems all
Caption: threads thought what they're doing so
Caption: can mark-and-sweep
Caption: 17 minutes of no activity for garbage
Caption: collection going back to this if I'm
Caption: allocating at every hundred and fifty to
Caption: a so if I'm garbage scoping every 150
Caption: second allocation or on next if I'm
Caption: pushing out about eight thousand
Caption: messages a second which was what we were
Caption: doing I would be garbage collecting 52
Caption: times a second and it sounds like I'm
Caption: not doing my work I'm doing something
Caption: else right so garbage collection for the
Caption: whim serialized don't synchronize I
Caption: found this interesting too another thing
Caption: that I was like surely it's going to be
Caption: all about hardware no wrong is about
Caption: measuring next thing surely concurrent
Caption: all the things is going to be the next
Caption: thing it wasn't I just thought
Caption: everything was going to be like throw
Caption: f-sharp and more calls at it and this
Caption: will be fine I was like no that's sit
Caption: down that's not a thing so this was
Caption: interesting avoid contended resources
Caption: and we all like we talk to sequel server
Caption: we talked to Oracle water and we know
Caption: that contending on that one big boy
Caption: makes it hard and the DBAs do fancy
Caption: things to make it safe and all this so
Caption: we will have people poking at our
Caption: content of resource and I use our
Caption: consequence and example that it could be
Caption: any old resource that could be the file
Caption: system that could be another web server
Caption: or something instead of everyone
Caption: continue on this and this having a
Caption: sophisticated locking strategy for its
Caption: complex internal workings do something
Caption: else
Caption: sorry put a simple data structure in
Caption: front of it like a cue contained on here
Caption: which is actually just contending on the
Caption: tail which is very simple to do and now
Caption: okay your contention cost here is like
Caption: what you can do is relax all your and
Caption: threading concerns you're locking
Caption: concerns here and this thing can run at
Caption: full speed as they are and that works it
Caption: really really works so single threaded
Caption: interestingly as well you need a code
Caption: easy to debug easy to test its
Caption: predictable by man and machine which I
Caption: found really interesting so I can look
Caption: at single threaded code and go I get
Caption: what that does all of us can look at
Caption: that code I had up I'm just going to go
Caption: add to buffer trim buffer push the I get
Caption: what that happens it in between it was
Caption: like mutex semaphore earlier I don't
Caption: know what's going on there but what's
Caption: also interesting predictable by man
Caption: predictable by machine if your code
Caption: single threaded and easy to understand
Caption: your CPU can start prefetching stuff
Caption: discs they stride through data very well
Caption: so if you are doing single threaded than
Caption: striding operations your whole computer
Caption: just heats up and starts doing what you
Caption: want it to do as opposed to keeping
Caption: actually out heating up shutting down
Caption: hang on I'm doing an undo it context
Caption: switch it just does what you want it to
Caption: do so unintended single threaded code
Caption: can run extremely fast
Caption: so then concurrency somewhere yes
Caption: concurrency but maybe not at a processor
Caption: level a sorry process level so instead
Caption: of having a process with lots of threads
Caption: all trying to do stuff make a process
Caption: dedicated to something so in the finite
Caption: space I might have a process dedicated
Caption: to buying and selling Netflix shares or
Caption: American chess or something you choose
Caption: your level of parallelism but beauty
Caption: about this is I can go right all GBP so
Caption: I Aussie dollar to Kiwi dollar can run
Caption: on that process and I can put all the
Caption: other lightweight currencies like owls
Caption: on there and then I can put British
Caption: Pound Sterling and America on its own
Caption: box or I can have more of them running
Caption: on their own box it's required
Caption: they tried not to do concurrency but if
Caption: required instead of locking said a lot
Caption: for your weight free and then consider
Caption: your target so you one threaded one
Caption: threads that should be thread safe in
Caption: case someone else does come along two to
Caption: three so single produce a single
Caption: consumer or another thing circular
Caption: buffers I found this really interesting
Caption: I don't want it uni and then thought
Caption: nothing of a server again
Caption: and at uni also was a janitor so that
Caption: was fun so for those who don't know and
Caption: I assume everyone does it's just an
Caption: array that's all it is
Caption: and when you get to the end you sort of
Caption: wrap back around and then it kind of
Caption: feels like a circularbuffer the nice
Caption: thing about these things is that the
Caption: head and the tail become very
Caption: uncontained 'add taking something off
Caption: this end doesn't really think putting
Caption: something on the other end it's kind of
Caption: nice constant space requirements which
Caption: is very nice for garbage collectors you
Caption: say allocate this upfront and then I'm
Caption: just going to keep using that same space
Caption: instead of putting on down mutating
Caption: stack or queue which I may choose
Caption: through allocations constant time to
Caption: push and pop that's nice for being
Caption: predictable latency if it's constant
Caption: time and it's poor to that now-famous
Caption: disruptor that the java boys have
Caption: produced that sort of them outstrip the
Caption: C++ boys and now Java runs one of the
Caption: fastest exchanges in the world which
Caption: again just blows my mind did a design to
Caption: run single code extremely fast or more
Caption: specifically single producer single
Caption: consumer but can also work with multi
Caption: producer Multi Siemens and still be
Caption: extremely fast and number ten
Caption: performance culture so if there's two
Caption: takeaways for today
Caption: first was know your flows draw and
Caption: visualize your flows try and find those
Caption: sneaky things like that in your code and
Caption: number two the other thing I really like
Caption: you to take away is this performance
Caption: culture where there was performance
Caption: there was diligence whenever I met these
Caption: guys or saw their code the code was
Caption: clean there's single responsibility
Caption: principle and act and action there were
Caption: repent intention revealing interfaces so
Caption: when you looked at their code you
Caption: understood what it was doing the
Caption: language was typed the domain was crisp
Caption: they use the right tool for the job and
Caption: less code code was the enemy if I had
Caption: more time I would have written this code
Caption: was the dogma that they were preaching
Caption: very interesting compared to some of the
Caption: other teams I worked on graph framework
Caption: became more code
Caption: we build an empire right that's not what
Caption: these guys are doing the primary
Caption: concepts we're not hidden
Caption: they weren't obstacle by accident and
Caption: they weren't obfuscated by mess or dirty
Caption: code and they weren't obfuscated to
Caption: protect the other devs it was a primary
Caption: concern it was put front and center and
Caption: she wanted to play in that code
Caption: basically to learn the primary concern
Caption: which probably meant you have to read
Caption: one page on a wiki to get up to speed
Caption: but you were you're there to program on
Caption: that thing you understood it very care a
Caption: lot of care was taken to make sure that
Caption: the core concepts remains the focus that
Caption: means build times will quick tests ran
Caption: fast deployments were quick they were
Caption: repeatable generalized concepts that
Caption: were distracting often got stripped down
Caption: and put into other libraries generally
Caption: open sourced which then became this
Caption: virtuous cycle so our build times got
Caption: quicker because we're just pulling in an
Caption: artifact instead of spinning cycles
Caption: building stuff someone else is looking
Caption: at the open source thing that we pushed
Caption: up so that got faster and ran better so
Caption: it was a cell into this virtuous cycle
Caption: and then all the sudden they're doing
Caption: something much better and faster than
Caption: other people and broken windows were
Caption: fixed anyone heard of the broken window
Caption: theory yes good so a theory in
Caption: criminology
Caption: about norms getting and signaling
Caption: behavior generally around vandalism you
Caption: want to work every day for a couple of
Caption: years and there's just one old tacky
Caption: building that no one uses and one Friday
Caption: you notice that windows broken here at
Caption: night it's a bit sad whatever go home
Caption: the weekend passes on Monday you walk
Caption: past and it's likewise there's this norm
Caption: setting the signal that was sent that no
Caption: one cares that when they got smashed
Caption: don't worry about it and so vandalism
Caption: kicks in because no one thinks anyone
Caption: cares about that that can happen in our
Caption: code bases that signaling effect you say
Caption: earlier builds red will do it on Monday
Caption: yeah all that we've got some warnings in
Caption: the code based on sort that later really
Caption: interestingly in the performance space -
Caption: it didn't fly that got fixed straight
Caption: away I was really impressed that it was
Caption: all the things we preached you know fix
Caption: the build
Caption: single responsibility principle that was
Caption: the secret source not get better
Caption: hardware or
Caption: something like that or concurrent all
Caption: the things it was the simple stuff I
Caption: thought that was really fascinating so
Caption: the beauty about our field is that it's
Caption: applied science so you don't have to
Caption: listen to anything I say it's great it's
Caption: not a theoretical science we can go and
Caption: prove all this kind of stuff is a single
Caption: producer single consumer thing faster
Caption: with a circular bustled go home in
Caption: prison grab benchmark dotnet or on one
Caption: of the Java tools and find out write
Caption: your own one this is kind of cool and
Caption: this is another thing that I learnt when
Caption: I was in London we don't have to have a
Caption: discussion and think about what might be
Caption: faster talk about what product might be
Caption: better is Jason better than protobufs
Caption: why are we talking about it open up the
Caption: laptop let's go to find out the stuff is
Caption: easy to do and the more you do it the
Caption: better you get at it and then you read
Caption: some blogs you find someone else has
Caption: already done it you pull down their
Caption: source coding you find out oh actually
Caption: we run a and B here and that's not true
Caption: on AMD oh that is true on and tell oh
Caption: we're running on essence or we're
Caption: running on funds oh this is different on
Caption: this platform we're in a practical
Caption: applied science you can prove this kind
Caption: of stuff it's fun to do so the top ten
Caption: know your targets know your costs know
Caption: you flows know your subsystems and know
Caption: your reasons then once you know your
Caption: things justify the cost be aware of your
Caption: GCS ouch serialize don't synchronized
Caption: circular buffers and performance culture
Caption: more information actually just grab hold
Caption: of me I've got so much I love talking
Caption: about this stuff do we have time yeah
Caption: cool anyone want to see something funny
Caption: or anyone got questions funny thing I
Caption: thought this was so neat yeah yeah so
Caption: bonus sections we will not have time for
Caption: this there twiddling so we're talking
Caption: about circular buffers before if I have
Caption: a 16 byte array a 16 size array and I
Caption: get to the end on my circular buffer how
Caption: do I get back to the start was a couple
Caption: of things we could do we could do the
Caption: old my method tail and the tail equals
Caption: the capacity branch go back to zero
Caption: that's cool or I can add one so I'm
Caption: either in the middle so add one or I'm
Caption: at the ends to go back to the start
Caption: that's one option
Caption: or I could use modulus that sounds kind
Caption: of cool so the capacity and the town
Caption: modulus gives me the index or I could
Caption: use a bit mask and that was kind of cool
Caption: I haven't done this bit twiddling stuff
Caption: in a while um does everyone remember the
Caption: first chart now you cause what looks
Caption: like a pretty expensive operation of the
Caption: math ones division what's modulus
Caption: division what the remainder isn't it so
Caption: that sounds expensive even though it's
Caption: very easy to write that looks really
Caption: quick it was funny when I benchmarked
Caption: this using benchmark net it's a free
Caption: tool how cool is that just go
Caption: open-source and now I can benchmark
Caption: things you probably can't read it cuz
Caption: projectors in black and purple 0.4
Caption: nanoseconds to do the branch plus add so
Caption: add one add one oh I got to the end go
Caption: back to 0.4 nanoseconds eight
Caption: nanoseconds for the modulus which is
Caption: probably what we thought of six
Caption: nanoseconds for a division for eight
Caption: nano seconds for a modulus this mask
Caption: can't calculate it zero if too fast it's
Caption: one CPU cycle and we're done thanks for
Caption: having me guys if you see Rob more about
Caption: giving my hugs is amazing